not so long ago it was a feature of high
school biology class that
biological sex is biologically real it's
detectable at the dna level you are born
with it you don't get to choose it just
as you don't get to choose your height
or your eye color your susceptibility to
breast cancer or a million other things
it's genetic genetics are real maybe
unfortunately but doesn't change the
truth of it
but now
that's hate speech
in his new special dave chappelle the
comedian explains what happens when you
challenge this lunatic new orthodoxy
it canceled people that are more
powerful than me
they canceled jk rowling my god jk
rowling wrote all the harry potter books
by herself
she sold so many books the bible worries
about her
and it canceled her because she said in
an interview and this is not exactly
what she said but effectually she said
gender was a fact
and then the trans community got mad
they started calling her a turf
i didn't even know what that was
but i know that
trans people make up words to win
arguments
well that's the truest thing ever said
making up words to win arguments you see
that in a lot of places now so none of
that's particularly radical it's pretty
conventional really four years ago no
one would have noticed it
but now a number of netflix employees
have decided to protest the special they
wanted pulled off of the service then
they harassed a man who came to support
chappelle in freedom of speech watch
this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's okay to laugh but you're sparking
hate conversations
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so they break his side and then they
accuse him he's left holding only a
stick accuse him of having a weapon
so his speech is violence their violence
is speech see how that works
what's interesting is that the number of
people who really care about this issue
enough to assault someone over it is
tiny and yet they have disproportionate
power 350 million people in the country
maybe 1100 feel that way but they're
running everything why is that well seth
dylan might know the answer he's ceo of
babylon b one of the very few remaining
satire sites of the entire internet he
joins us tonight seth thanks so much for
coming on so you you this stuff's in
your face every single day you're the
target of a lot of this
you gotta wonder the people trying to
destroy your business and your life like
they're a tiny percentage of americans
aren't they
they are but they wield all the power
this is the funny thing you know it's it
they really are the joke at this point
because they they try to project
themselves as being marginalized these
are the marginalized these are the
oppressed
but you can't make fun of them you know
the way that you can tell who holds all
the power in a society is by who you
can't make fun of right that's right
these are the people that you can't make
fun of so it's very clear they hold all
the institutional power in our culture
and it's really interesting you know
when you've got comedians like chappelle
you got to worry about now when you're
telling jokes not you don't just ask
yourself is this funny you have to ask
yourself is this joke going to offend
somebody who's more powerful than me but
identifies as being marginalized because
i might lose my career
so is that i mean
your site manages to be consistently
funny and i think probably most of our
viewers get you know babylon b headlines
texted to them at least once a day how
big a concern is that for you i mean do
you feel like you're right on the edge
of getting your business taken away from
you
well i mean that's the goal right
there's there's like 10 different ways
they're trying to attack comedy one of
them it's not even intentional they're
making reality absurd that whole opening
you did with kamala harris and joe biden
and all these videos and how fake they
are like it's impossible to satirize
that these people are beyond parody
they've turned reality into a parody of
itself so that's that's one way then
there's the intentional way they fact
check jokes they try to rate them false
they can get them taken down for
misinformation then they try to accuse
you of hate speech under the guise of
satire or comedy like what they're doing
with chappelle and saying that his jokes
are beyond the pale they hurt people but
really it's the people it's the joke
police it's the people who are who are
saying oh his jokes hurt my feelings you
know those are the people they deserve
to be mocked more not less because it's
just silly to act like joke police like
jokes really are are like violence
really like you said earlier you know
the speech is now violence and the
violence is speech uh you know jokes are
not violent they don't hurt anybody uh
if we're all equal we should all be able
to joke about each other
indiscriminately and not have these this
like hierarchical structure where we
have certain people who are off limits
and we can't joke about them if we're
all equal boy you got right to the heart
of it there if we're all equal only in a
country where we're all considered
equals can that happen but that's we're
we're not that country anymore you're
exactly right seth dylan i appreciate
your coming on and your site which i
love hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else